in slow-mo seeing it cut through can
after can after can that was pretty cool
max McCarter is a self-taught swordsmith
making weapons that increase your odds
of surviving a zombie apocalypse we were
hanging out on a sword shop and the idea
came up hey why don't we make swords
specifically geared for the zombie
apocalypse maxes online video
demonstrates a newly made samurai sword
sharpness by slicing 24 Samba fight beer
cans at once
so what is it about Max's sword that
lets him cut through beer cans like
butter that needs to be moving very
quickly it needs to be very sharp and he
has to do this KN after I can after can
so the blade needs to be heavy as well
to continue the momentum it also helps
that the cans are shaped like a cylinder
because as the blade comes in the
initial point of contact is tiny
therefore you have this massive force
hitting at a very focused point so the
pressure is enormous and that's why he
can split the cannon too so a super
sharp blade with a lot of momentum
produces epic pressures on the swords
edge but how did max slice through all
24 cans to transform all the potential
energy stored in his muscles into such a
straight line and a beautifully
conserved velocity then you have to have
an amazing technique so you have to
drive power from your toes and your hips
but without changing your level and
that's the trick to it
guess it's more dangerous to attack a
pressurized can of beer than a zombie
huh is there something you're not
telling us max I want to reassure our
viewers that no beer was harmed in the
making this video we respect beer and
the beer was drunk and the cans were
empty and filled with water